So what happens?
Well,
Kane makes his offerings and God isn't
happy with them.
Now we don't know how cain figures out
that God isn't happy with his offerings.
We get some hints of that too.
But the story does tell us that's what
happens.
And so then we get the psychological
response on the part of cane.
Now one response could be,
Jesus,
I must be doing something wrong.
I better straighten myself out,
you know,
I better come up with a better quality
offering and try that again.
That isn't what happens.
What happens instead is that cane
becomes angry wroth and his countenance
fault.
And so what does that mean?
It means this,
right?
It means he is not happy.
He's angry and out for revenge.
And so one of the.
I've been thinking about this a lot
lately with regards to the literature on
inequality,
because there's a very good literature
that shows,
for example,
that there's a,
there's a,
there's a measure called the Gini
Coefficient.
The Gini Coefficient is a numerical
index of the relative inequality of a
geographical locale.
So for example,
if you went to Newfoundland where
everyone is roughly not very rich or
North Dakota,
say almost everyone there is say lower
middle class,
something like that,
or upper working class,
something like that.
Very little variability,
low Gini Coefficient,
okay?
And if you go to Miami Beach,
say where everyone's rich,
low gini coefficient,
because it isn't an index of absolute
wealth or absolute poverty,
it's an index of relative poverty.
And so if everyone's rich,
the relative poverty is low,
and if everyone's poor,
the relative poverty is low.
Now one question is where's the crime?
And you might think,
well,
the crime is where the absolute poverty
is high,
right?
Or the absolute wealth is low.
That's where the crime is.
That's wrong.
If it's.
If things are relatively distributed in
an egalitarian manner,
the male on male crime,
especially homicide is low and it's also
the case where everyone is rich.
But if you go into places where there's
some rich people but not very many,
and there's a lot of people who are
comparatively poor than the male
homicide rapes rates and violent crime
rates amp up substantially.
And it's a consequence of male on male
competition,
and so what you could derive from that
and maybe even reasonably is that you
should flatten out the damn income into
distribution because you're
destabilizing this society by
facilitating male criminal aggression.
You can make a good case for that.
You know,
in,
in places like Columbia where the Gini
Coefficient got unbelievably extreme,
society got so violent that it could
barely hold itself together.
So,
so you,
you can make a conservative argument for
redistribution of income using the
observation that if the income
distribution gets too extreme,
the whole bloody thing starts to
destabilize.
It might fall,
but,
but then you also might say,
wait a minute,
is it any quality that's driving the
violence or is it resentment of the
inequality that's driving the violence?
Now,
that's a tough question because you
might say,
well,
what if the game is rigged and there's
no way of moving up the power hierarchy?
Well then maybe anger and the desire for
revolution is the appropriate response.
But that doesn't really mean to me that
the response should be that sort of
thing that you see in hygienic
coefficient neighborhoods,
which is interracial,
intra racial violence between men.
So for example,
in neighborhoods where there's high
murder rates,
the murders are always between young men
and they're always within race.
And so that doesn't seem to me to be
exactly a politically revolutionary
move,
right?
It's more like it's more like a violent
competition for the sake of,
of,
of attaining status.
And you might say,
well that's reasonable,
but because the inequality is there and
then need to find status because it's
part of what drives them forward.
It's part of what makes them attractive
to women.
It's a necessity.
Well,
the question is,
do you attain status through destruction
or do you start making your offerings,
putting your offerings in order?
And that's something we really need to
figure out because that's a fundamental
political question.
It's a fundamental political question.
Anyways.
What happens in this story is that cane
decides that the fact that God isn't
accepting his offerings means that he's
entitled to become angry and,
and,
and negative.
Those two things or both put together
right?
He's raw,
he's angry,
and he's also depressed and so he's in a
state of mind that,
well,
I think the best characterization for
that as hostile resentment because it's
unfair.
It's like,
yeah,
it's unfair,
so we're going to do about it.
Can you get destructive about it?
Are going to change your approach?
Well,
Kane,
he does the ultimate thing and this is
what people do when they do the ultimate
thing because that kind of hostile
resentment has an architectural end
point and the architectural end point is
the point that you get when you're
hostile and resentful because you
haven't been successful and then you go
sit in your mother's basement for about
10 years and then you start imagining
just how nice it would be if you shut up
the local high school so that everybody
knew your name and what happens is you
go from I'm irritated because things
aren't working out for me very well too.
I'm irritated.
Nine and a hate.
Those people for whom things are working
out well too.
I'm irritated and I hate the fact that
the world is set up so that this has
happened to me and then you go to well
because I'm irritated and hate the
world.
I'm going to do whatever I can that will
destroy it most rapidly and with the,
with the highest possible amount of pain
and suffering conceivable and at that
point then you don't just go shoot up
the high school.
You go up and shoot up the elementary
school and so if you're wondering what
kind of pathway people walk down to get
to that point,
that's the pathway and the ultimate cap
of that as well.
I'll,
I'll kill the kids because well we
already know that killing the innocent
is a lot more effective than killing the
guilty.
And then just to cap it off,
I'll blow my head off at the end just to
show you just how God damn pointless it
all is.
And so that's the logical extension of
keynes attitude and you might think,
well that's a bit of an overeating and I
will say it's not an overriding and all.
It's exactly what happens in the text.
So it's,
it's exactly what follows it.
So foreign.
So Kane is not happy.
And so who was he not happy with?
Well,
he's not happy with God.
And so what does that mean?
Well,
we've already unpacked this.
He's not happy with the social contract
because that's part of the spirit,
the patriarchal spirit,
let's say.
Then there's more to it than that
because we already,
we've already analyzed what God,
the idea of God might represent in the
background of this story.
He's not happy with the transcendent.
He's not happy with the idea of the
logos,
all of that.
No faith in the transcendent,
nothing but he does nothing but despise
the social contract.
And he's got no faith whatsoever in the
logos.
Let's say the word that brings chaos out
of order.
He's got nothing but contempt for all of
that.
And you know,
certainly,
you know,
people like that.
And if you don't know them,
you just go on youtube and read the
comments and you'll see all sorts of
people like that.
So.